role on the motion of retain for house
bill 481 if you're in favor
please say yes if you're opposed please
say no
okay chairman over yes vice chairman
emmerich
yes the clerk uh robert t bergevocs
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
representative hatch representative
walsh
yes voted seven to nothing madam
chairman
the motion to retain house bill 481 is
unanimous
and will be recommended to the full
committee
the next bill on our docket is house
bill 498
relative to the payment of bail
commissioners relative to death benefits
for public works
employees killed in the line of duty and
relative to workers compensation offsets
for certain retirement system benefits
again this bill has money attached to it
um no i think i read i'm sorry i read
two titles together
they're so close together this is
relative to the payment of bail
commissioners
and is there any discussion by any
member of the committee on this bill
[Music]
moves to retain is there a second
representative
griffin seconds on the motion to retain
house bill 498
is there any discussion
see none apparently we need coffee this
morning to talk
or we're holding it for later i'm not
sure see none if you're in favor of the
motion to retain when the clerk calls
your name
if please vote yay if you're opposed
please vote nay
chairman representative ober yes
chairman of vice chairman
representative emmerich the clerk votes
yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
yes representative hatch representative
waltz
yes man and chairman the vote is seven
nothing
the motion to retain is unanimously
approved seven to nothing
now we will move to hp 536 and i already
read part of that description
with the other bill so i'm going to read
again this one
is relative to death benefits for public
works employees killed in the line of
duty
and relative to workers compensation
offsets for
certain retirement system benefits any
discussion on this bill
hopefully retain house bill 536
representative emerick moves to retain
house bill 536
is there a second representative griffin
seconds is there any discussion on the
motion to retain
if not the clerk will call you your name
when if you are in favor of the motion
to retain please vote yes if you're
opposed please vote no
representative ober yes representative
emmerich yes
uh representative alex the clerk ots
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yay representative walsh yes
madam chairman the vote of seven nothing
the motion passes
unanimously this bill is retained and
the last bill
on our agenda
is hb 591 relative to certain liquor
license fees
um not only should this be in the budget
but we haven't even had the liquor
committee in so we don't
know any position but is there any
discussion on this bill
madam charlie moved to retain house bill
591 representative emerick moves to
retain house bill 591
is there a second representative
griffin seconds any discussion on the
motion to retain
seen none if you're in favor of the
motion to retain house bill 591 when
your name is called please vote yay
if you're opposed please vote nay the
clerk will call the rule when he is
ready
madam chairman yes vice chairman emerick
yes the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
yes representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yay representative walsh yes
madam chairman the voter seven nothing
the motion to retain
passes unanimously that is all of our
bills
and now we actually have about 45
minutes
to find that cup of coffee so we maybe
become a little more
chatty so i'm going to ask
representative emmerich
to mute and stop the room and the other
people
work session commissioner caswell is
with
us commissioner we have two members at
home representative patch and
representative walls you can see
representative walls already on the
screen
the rest of us are here we also have two
lba members
online who help us so
welcome to division one for everybody
watching at home this budget starts on
page
579 and the commissioner has just given
us a handout which i think
mr tuberge is working on passing out
welcome to division one and thank you
for coming you're on your live
commissioner thank you representative
nice to be here uh nice to see everybody
uh in person uh for the first time in a
while
um i wanted to just say give a couple of
quick overviews and leave our time for
it the discussion
uh component yeah we want we do want to
go through your budget and understand it
yep so just a couple of highlights i
would
i would i would put for the committee um
first of course you know we're con we've
continued through this whole pandemic at
the department
um really working uh with our business
community and with stakeholders around
the state on a whole host of issues
at the least of which is uh working with
the gopher
team which is in our office at the bea
and
making those programs work effectively
together
overall our budget for this upcoming
biennium is proposed at a 17
reduction in general fund expenditures
over the previous biennium i'm going to
walk through
a couple of quick highlights for each of
our major divisions the first being the
division of economic development
as i mentioned this staff has been
really central to our
response to the recovery uh and
throughout this pandemic over the last
couple of months
we do have some new leadership down at
our office of workforce opportunity
and they've been really active in
working with employers
who are struggling and looking for
services around rapid response and
those types of programs and and we work
very closely with our friends at
employment security
uh on that front in the ded budget we
see a reduction of roughly 13 in general
fund expenditures
which are the three handouts that we
have here i'm sorry the handouts that i
gave you is one the letter in response
to your questions
yeah i got that and now we've got three
spreadsheets so i don't know which one
to look
there are two spreadsheets and i haven't
gotten to those yet okay um
um and i'll i'll let you know so where
in your budget should we look then
because we do have your budget so the
budget you're talking about where should
we
i'm just giving you the overall
highlights the reduction numbers all
right okay
um we could skip all that if you'd like
i'll just get right to it we just
look at those pesky details you know how
we are well they didn't have percentages
so i thought i would i would give you
some
okay um so the uh the reduction that we
saw in dd is primarily in our marketing
class lines and the travel budgets are
obviously reduced
a lot of our travelers normally to
conferences recruitment efforts
and our international team does travel
internationally
normally of course we're not going to
have that at least in the fir in fiscal
year 22 from our understanding and
probably at a limited amount in 23.
and also we did take a look at all of
the subscription services that we use
many of which we could probably be
without for for uh for this coming year
and
share some data resources with other
agencies if necessary
over at travel and tourism um this uh
this obviously continues to be something
that is really important to us
given the role the the impact that's
occurred to the hospitality industry
over the last couple of months
particularly we maintained some level of
marketing activity in key markets
throughout the pandemic
but overall that reduction amounted to
about 3.1 million dollars that
of our in our summer campaign last year
that we did not spend
that um under accounting unit 2019 is a
non-lapsing fund so
that's going to continue to turn through
this coming summer
fall and winter campaigns um
but we did a lot of in-state marketing
with those resources this year
we did the early on when it was to stay
at home
we wanted people to be able to stay
within new hampshire
and so we did a lot of marketing in that
respect also
in support of small businesses with our
a couple of campaigns that we ran
stronger together uh emphasizing the
need for people to get out
when they can safely and uh and and
visit local businesses and restaurants
um so overall the travel tourism
reduction for this biennium is
roughly about 20 general fund reductions
again
most of that is in the reduction uh of
our marketing budgets
um but also we did eliminate the
film office within the division of
travel and tourism
we made reductions of about a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars per year in
the joint promotional program
uh and again in the out of state travel
category we saw some
pretty significant reductions there
in the bureau of visitor services which
is the rest areas and welcome centers
they were closed for a good portion of
the pandemic in the height of the
pandemic
we're currently operating at a somewhat
reduced schedule
slightly fewer hours and then closed on
tuesdays and thursdays
this is a result of some reductions we
made in expenditures but also it's
extremely difficult to find people
at this point to staff the work uh staff
the centers
so that's been an ongoing challenge for
our staff there overall
between the turnpike and general funds
that reduction was around 15
total and then um
the hb2 provisions that uh
uh i wanted to address there's a couple
in there but the highlights really i
mentioned the film office
reduction happy to talk about it section
we do have hb2 things as well yep
um film office was
54. section 54. so if you're at home
looking at this section 54.
so that's a reduction by by cutting that
office
savings about 265 000 of the biennium
and one labor grade 29 position
[Music]
most of it is salary and benefits cost
obviously the film industry has changed
substantially
and that office was
really something that we can handle
within our division of travel
tourism is our feeling on that
on the economic development fund i know
you had a question about that which is
under section 52.
hb2 that is just ex that that
the language in that was meant to just
be a housekeeping
update there were some
references to organizations that no
longer exist
so we just replaced some of those with
some of our current stakeholders like
chambers of commerce and regional
development corporations and so on
there's no money in that fund
but that you know with the anticipation
potentially of
stimulus funds from washington
potentially flowing through
state agencies i just wanted to update
that one section so that's the only
there's nothing substantive other than
some changes in housekeeping measures
there
i'm the director of intergovernmental
affairs which is
section 53 53 thank you
um that is taking an existing classified
position
and transferring it to an unclassified
the goal there would be to keep that a
cost neutral
transition the reason for that change is
that
we do a tremendous amount of work with
other state agencies with local
governments
with town managers and with the federal
government
and here with the legislature and so
having a position that can cut across
all of our divisional areas
economic development travel tourism
workforce development and so on
um is a position that i feel strongly
that we need to be able to have
um so that we are consistent in those
relationships
what is the current title of that
position the current
title is an industrial agent at large
grade 25.
and you're proposing to take it to what
grade
well i do believe it's subject to a
market analysis but
we uh looked at grade cc
as an equivalent to the current grade
level
what's the difference in the salary
salary would be
uh
approximately that would save around
fourteen hundred dollars per year
assuming that it came through they would
get a lower salary slightly lower yes
overall it would be a little lower we
were at a step five for that labor grade
this would be a grade cc step one
and does he know you or she know you're
proposing to lower their
yearly intake uh there's no one in the
position currently
so it's currently vacant that's right so
it was uh
someone left and went to another agency
so i took advantage of that
so we're not lowering anybody's no ma'am
all right
thank you sorry i should have made that
clear
[Music]
excellent point however um
the last piece here really uh all go
together
and are some of the handouts that i gave
you
are with regard to the office of
planning and development
which uh under hb2 um in the transition
to the new department of energy would
move
that division from the office of
strategic initiatives
to the department of business and
economic affairs
there was some money that was
accommodated for
in the osi budget for
um for them for the move over but we
will have to
expand the lease that we have in our
offices across the street
at 100 north main street in order to
accommodate additional staff
so that's the primary source of the
supplemental requests that i handed out
to you
those costs all total between moving
and new lease costs a new printer rental
and some small additional telecom and
doit
costs comes to um
eighty thousand dollars in fy twenty two
and sixty thousand dollar roughly
in fy23 i have also
added in here um
a request for 20 000 in
each fiscal year for employee training
for the office of planning
uh this is an area where uh we did this
with our
economic development staff when we moved
them over from dred and it was highly
effective in getting them up to speed on
everything that's going on i
am not aware that that's been made
available to that staff for some time
now so i did put that request in there
um as it relates to um the planning
division
what are the titles of the people you're
getting you're getting six people right
yes um i'm going on memory now
ma'am it's uh out i think there's a 20
labor grade 27
um at uh in two two or
two twenty four two twenty fives and
maybe a twenty three
i'm going to have to get back to you on
the exact numbers i don't have that
right in front of me
so i can tell you the representative
leishman's going to ask you a question
i can tell you that the governor's
budget director
has said this is cost neutral there will
be no additional cost
so they apparently are not including
any of these increases that you're
requesting
is that correct uh our assessment is at
this point that we would have to have
somewhere to put them
and that that cost was not anticipated
when they
um when they the the transmission
we have yet to hear from the governor's
budget director but he is coming to talk
about the department
of energy and the reorgan we knew six
people had gone to you so i just wanted
to
be sure representation you had to put
your hand up
thanks man
i'm curious on
[Music]
we've got the uh business development
centers
um that was in the category of difficult
budget decisions to be made
i think yes as you indicate we have a
a good relationship with the sbdc
there's also if you look under um
somewhere right after that is the irc
which is another program that we fund
uh the university of new hampshire to um
to invest either it is it's i'm sorry
accounting unit 1457.
uh that those two programs are both
funds that we provide the university of
new hampshire
as match to grants that they apply for
from the united states small business
administration
the decision was made that those two
programs
probably could find some additional
income from
other sources to carry the program
for the biennium and so that's the
reason why
we had to make that difficult decision i
know that
the governor sent over a supplemental
priority
request was it last week and
the restoring that to the 315 was
included
in that priority request so this remains
an open question in our budget however
we zeroed those two programs
i think the governor sent that over as
an additional request because i did let
the budget director know that
none of us had usable emails anymore
because we've been flooded with people
complaining about the cut in the small
business development center
so it has really hit
a note with many of our constituents yes
ma'am
i have heard from them as well
[Music]
follow-up representative eastman
if you can hold that one because we are
going to have the governor's
budget director come and talk to us in
general
and i think the commissioner probably
was asked to take the planning people as
part of it but not did not initiate it
so that's a very valid question
but maybe we could hold that until we
get uh
mr melu in here and he will be happy to
answer that for you
okay one more and then representative
waltz will follow you
so after your question representative
leitchman
that's correct so they they uh they
they're required to provide a match
in order to access the federal resource
and and again there isn't any statutory
requirement that the state
provide that match so that was what we
were hanging our hat on as it relates to
being able to find a reduction
that was sufficient to meet the targets
that we were asked to meet
okay representative walls yes and i just
wanted to say
i didn't know if the commissioner was
aware that we had i'd heard from the
small
business development council and they
said they will have to shut down without
this state money
that whatever you think is coming on a
federal match is apparently not and is
not enough to keep them open and the
director
personally told me she expects that they
will have to shut down if they do not
get this money
so i just wanted to correct any
misunderstanding about that and perhaps
suggest that you may want to reach out
to her and hear from yourself
how dire this cut would be
thank you ma'am i i have spoken to liz
and with
dean merrill sands at university of new
hampshire
okay uh commissioner i think
we can move on yes ma'am
okay let's uh move
taylor why don't you pull that
microphone closer to you i don't know
how sensitive they are
but if representative hatch is having
troll i know in
and now he's shaking his head thank you
is that better representative can you
hear me better
i could always um hear you commissioner
it's just uh
other people asking questions i had
trouble hearing actually what you did
pull it back because it's a little more
fuzzy there that's better
okay thank you thank you madam chair
you're welcome representative patch
asking i'm sorry mountain chair it's a
participant asking
questions that i can't hear i'm i'm not
sure about bearing best but thank you
thank you representative emery and you
pull that microphone a little closer as
well
thank you madam i could not hear
representative leishman either i was
getting a little bit
his we're addressing that mary beth
we're addressing this
but one at a time and now as
representative emerick's got his hand up
i i fairly stubborn on the small
business development center
because it looks like if you look at
their performance
their return on investments very high
and i know i know several businesses in
my town and immediate area
that they've supported and have cont
continued to consult with i know they
have representation throughout the state
so it's not a concord-centric operation
and i think based on roi
their performance is stellar
so i don't know what measurement you use
to say let's don't have performance
let's have
somebody else pay for it i i think
you're shooting your feet off here
uh because i look up up above the
federal funds that are coming in for
workforce
opportunity and you said that's working
with main street businesses
uh due to the pandemic and the feds seem
to want to invest a lot of money in that
uh and and we're throwing in for 75 000
and then eighty thousand the next
biennium
i'd i'm i'm at a loss quite honestly is
that you would discontinue something so
successful
out of hand well again our intention is
not to discontinue the program
we believe that the program can continue
to operate with additional funding
perhaps even from the university of new
hampshire
as a match if that's not the case then
by all means i think that that's
something that this committee should
review
i would also say that as relates to the
office of workforce opportunity those
are funds that we receive from the
division
department of labor to provide adult
dislocation services
for workforce development and for rapid
response
to businesses that are unfortunately
having to lay off individuals
plus the youth displacement programs
which provide
resources for students that are have
dropped out of high school are in danger
of dropping after high school in order
to give them
training for workforce so so i think
that there is
we when we had to look at the priorities
of the department
workforce became a high priority for our
department
across the board that's what employers
are most concerned with at this point
i'm not saying that it was an easy
decision to come up with these numbers
that we put in here for the sbdc or the
ir city
but in the scope of what we were asked
to be able to come up with in terms of
targets
in terms of reduction of close to 20 of
our general fund budget
um those were unfortunate decisions that
we had to make
and i don't disagree with your
assessment as to the effectiveness of
the program but i do think that there
would be other opportunities
in a crisis situation to find additional
funding to make that match for a period
of a year or two years
commissioner let me give you a little
fact of life for house finance
we have to have the budget finished and
approved by the end of march because
of house deadlines and you have you have
time for lba to get things together
moving on
we don't even have final march revenues
we know that
and then business taxes as you and i
both know come in
in april and may and that's a big jump
so when we when the budget gets
to the senate the senate always has
actually more dollars than we had
so we're trying to balance here and
there and i can tell you that
probably what you're going to see happen
is some of your funding in some areas
are going to get cut in order to put
some money back into the small business
development center we hear what you're
saying we're hopeful when it gets to the
senate the economy keeps turning around
they've got the money
anything we cut here you can restore
plus get some money out to small
business
centers so i think we hear you but i
also think we're going to have to make
some
decisions we feel like there needs to be
a little more money in there so
we're going to try to work with you to
make that happen at the least amount of
impact we appreciate where you were
coming from and
you're i guess i'm going to say
restraints because i know what the
governor was dealing with during the
pandemic and you guys started this
last summer which most people don't know
so while most of us were home
pandemic was really raging you're trying
to work on a budget for the next two
years so we appreciate the work
you're gonna just expect to see a few
cuts and go the senate
i mean i'm gonna say to gary daniels and
chuck morris listen we know you got more
money here's what we had to do we didn't
like but we
we need to have money in there so
representative emerick did you have a
follow-up
no madam chair i feel we're moving into
an argumentative position yeah we're not
going to argue with him because he knows
what he had to do we understand it was
he was making a budget last summer which
i don't think a lot of people in the
public understand these
budget books of a thousand pages don't
show up
overnight after november when we're
getting a little better so
we do know that could you answer a
question for me on
workforce opportunity what do you use
your general funds for and where would i
find those
and i'm looking at page 588 where i see
the general funds are you you're
adjusted authorized were 80
021 you cut it to about 76 and 22
and back up to 8023 what do you spend
those on and where are those because
that might be an area we kind of cut
back because i can see
that several years ago in 2020 you only
spent 200
and now i've got a little money i can
put it into small business which
clearly there's a feeling across the
state we need to refund
we need to fund it some level
yes ma'am i see that i don't have a good
answer for you right now but that
program
is almost exclusively federally funded i
can see that
yep uh and so i'm going to uh have to
say that i would give you that
information later today
that would be fine thank you i mean now
we're looking to cut we're looking to
cut some general fund pennies that don't
you hoping what happens in the
senate you heard me
you know where we're going yes ma'am we
know the constraints you were under we
appreciate it
and i'm happy to work with you on all
those points all right so
please continue if you could
um i think i pretty much hit everything
that i was going to
um we um go to your budget
and why don't we just leaf through
and ask our questions so uh for
members at home we're on page 579
and do i see any questions from
any of my division members on page 579
represent walls yeah i have a general
question that it's precipitated by this
and that is
are there going to be any layoffs within
your department
he's laid off one position i believe he
spoke to that
he's repealed that entire agency
the only positions he's gaining are
gifts from the department of energy
reorganization which
um the governor's budget director will
come speak and answer
all of our questions on that he is being
scheduled for that and he knows that
that's correct isn't it correct i knew
it was defunded it was not clear to me
with the paper available to me whether
there was an actual layoff so thank you
so much
i think that's you'll find that in your
budget book all right let's turn to
page 580 and you talked in
in general about the safety rest areas
this is a
an area my friend represent patch
frequently has a question on
um representative burris do you have a
question on this
yes thank you commissioner for being
here
um up north in coast county on route two
between uh which goes east to west
between
maine and vermont you're aware that
there are no rest areas
yes we constantly representative hatch
to myself being
from coast county he i'm from berlin
he's from gorham
continuously get complaints because of
the lack of arrest area
are there any plans in the near future
to restore that
well i know we've had discussion um
with representative hatch and d.o.t on
the shelburne the former shelburne
restaurant
and i believe now my recollection was
that when we
worked with dot they were in the midst
of
transferring ownership of that property
to a local campground
when we had this discussion two years
ago i believe that since then
um that deal has fallen apart
representative hatch may know better
than i do
and he's got his hand up so he'll yeah
and and so my understanding is that that
property
as one of i think it was about five or
six
rest areas that were closed prior to my
time here
remains closed and vacant
and in dot ownership but other than that
i'm not aware of any other opportunities
on route 2
for rest areas representative hatch
yes um thank you madam chair just just a
couple things on the rest area
and i know it's a complicated mess that
existed long before your existence
there but um as representative tuber
said i
i wouldn't uh would hope
that you would um take an active role
in rectifying that issue particularly
with the shelburne
uh rest area i think that's uh something
there solvable
it's something we've been dealing with
for i don't know uh representative leach
and
leachman may have a better idea but for
quite a few years
then i and i feel as though it's been
ignored that's one thing
enough said secondly um
a few years ago in speaking of breast
areas
i had a suggestion to you that
work with the csep program that's where
uh
older individuals are hired or retired
individuals
in many cases um you're paid for by the
csep
pro it's a senior citizens employment
program
um rest areas would be an ideal fit
for that um i know of one person that
was from the cseps program in the
littleton rest area but
other than that have you actively
pursued that
um i think and i'll stop after this um
that's something that should have been
developed and it's a very strong
program viable program and so how much
are you using it now commissioner
uh representative uh you fit on a really
important point here which is that
some of the in my experience now i have
two years of plus
with this program i can make a couple of
observations one is
the rest areas are exceptionally
difficult to operate
due to the staffing constraints that we
have so
the jobs that are there pay extremely
low
and increasingly in a lot of our rest
areas
particularly in the southern tier being
open
into the evenings in other words
occasionally
are put in difficult situations whether
they're homeless people that are
at the site whether there's drug use at
the site which has occurred
there's not a regular police presence
there and then add in
the pandemic and the fact that you know
while we do
everything we can to protect our staff
in those situations it is
increasingly difficult to find people to
put in those jobs
and that is the height the most limiting
factor
i would say to to our ability to
continue to maintain those
the maintenance budgets the costs the
we've made some pretty
decent improvements some of some of them
are things that you don't see
septic tanks electrical upgrades
water systems wi-fi those sorts of
things have all been improved over the
last couple of years
but the staffing is extremely i will say
a challenge for many reasons
maintaining staff and then when we had
to do
the close down during a good portion of
last spring a lot of those people didn't
just did not come back
we made every effort to move a lot of
those individuals into other positions
like at the liquor commission
several of them did do that and some of
them have come back
but that is our largest challenge
representative and it's
uh even with the additional funds that
were provided last time to
keep all of our areas open um um
um through throughout the year the the
fact
that remained was the staffing issue
so i'm not looking to make excuses
representative i'm just telling you
that's my observation at this point that
that's a real challenge and
and going after in some cases you know
maybe
uh some of the programs that you're
referencing would be would be good but
i'm not
sure that's always the best choice in
places like hampton or salem
um and others i agree but
it's something i think could be utilized
a little bit better i'm very familiar
with the program
and i know of several several
individuals
that are placed in it it's a great
benefit
and they uh overcome all those
challenges you spoke to but
thank you commissioner just uh please
follow up on that thank you i will
follow up with you representative
representative hatch sounds like you
might have an opportunity for a bill
next year
um you've got the familiarity and maybe
it would so just you maybe you and the
commissioner can take that up offline
and see if it can go anywhere
thank you madam chair all right
commissioner i
we're leaving that workers comp money is
all
other funds bringing us to the office
of the commissioner
um
we talked about turnpikes yeah
you're doing that i'm turn to the top of
page 584.
i see general funds but i also see a
significant decrease in general funds
again the big numbers there are in the
in the marketing budget was a reduction
of 275 000
of the biennium um out-of-state travel
and some of our subscription services
and so on under class 102.
representative tubers
oh i'm sorry yes sir
taylor we have these wonderful pieces of
equipment one here and one back there
cleans the air five times an hour
with all kinds of fancy things to make
sure we don't give you any horrible
diseases
but they run all the time quite loudly
they don't run in a quiet mode they are
full blast all day long all right noted
i'll speak up
thank you okay
uh procurement and government contracts
the bottom of page 585.
your general fund use has gone up here
what's going up there
and i'm sorry where are you now i'm now
and it says the estimated source of
funds for procurement government
contracts and
it shows the general funds going from
126 9
to 157
uh yes i see that uh one
yep um again
i might need to get back to you unless
um
i think my business manager is on the
line she might be able to answer that
phone let me see
if hallie uh nessie there she is ellie
she is hang on a minute hallie you're
about to join us
hallie should now be with us
yes ali if you unmute yourself you can
answer
the question we have the technology
hi good morning good morning thank you
for having me um
so we did something we moved some
rent around last uh biennium all the
rent was in class
207 on the first page and
we reallocated it to all the
divisions that have federal funds so
that
oh the office of workforce opportunity
could pay their
part yet the rest of it was transferred
to um ptac and one other unit i believe
um it's still being paid with general
funds but it had to be allocated
to all of the federal funded agent
divisions in order for oboe to pay it if
that makes sense
it's just transparent money so we have
we have several federally funded offices
yep uh and we wanted them all to be
paying rent that's class
22. so yes she's right we see that thank
you commissioner and thank you hallie
thank you
don't don't go away he we may have
another question for you who knows
all right workforce opportunity we have
discussed you guys have any more
questions at this time the majority of
that
nearly 10 million dollars is federal
funds
allie you don't happen to know where the
general funds are in there do you
yes ma'am um they are parts of two
positions
in the department um not everything they
do
is always reimbursable by the federal
department
and in some cases where grants what
went longer than they should have the
grant funds ran out
so it's really it's 50 of two positions
just so you know i think when you get
those grants it does say general funds
will not be used
to displace when they run out they go
away
you bring those to fiscal that really is
what's supposed to happen representative
uh thanks man of chair and pull that
microphone close so
represent patch can hear you i don't
know if he wants to though
i don't think so there he is
um i'm glad you're here with us because
i
i'm just curious again what maybe the
commissioner touched on this these
different transfers
49 and 85 did you explain because
there's
we're going from a half a million
dollars and 49 to zero
and then down in 85 we're going from
zero to 5.2 million is that have
anything to do with the department of
energy
those six positions that the chair
mentioned earlier
um i'm sorry representative where are
you what page i'm on page
587 587
so last line 49 and 85.
that's the consultant class line no 46
i'm sorry transfer
which one which lines are you on peter
49 madam chair
transferred to other state agencies yes
going to zero and then
an 85 going from zero to 5.2 million
this caught my eye
harley do you know that yes those are
actually moved to
um 0.85 again a technical thing where
we were just requested to pay it out of
a different class
where did it go it went to 085
so those two numbers the transfers went
don't really match up as far as the
transfer amount
well i think that yeah no
it's and there's some of 102 went into
85 as well
so just a follow-up so could you tell us
more on this transfer amount what that
breaks down
transfers out of f
i'm sorry i didn't understand the
question
on the class 80 class line 85 hallie
where we um
what is the full title because we have
interagency transfers out of f and so
there must be something
that goes beyond f i i'm sorry i don't
know the answer to that
it's cut off in the um yeah it's cut
open ours too
maybe you could get that we'll get that
for you it's an awful lot of money if
it's
all of a sudden all right commissioner
add that to your list
yep thank you
i will say just generally in those
instances
representative there there were a couple
of places where we had to reassemble
based on the transfer over from dread
which had um different use different
class
lines we when hallie came on board which
is just about a year ago
we went through and made some
adjustments so that they made more sense
so
once we get the answer i'm sure it will
make more sense
okay so now we're on 589 which of course
is going to be
the small business development center
and i think we all know where we stand
on that it currently is funded at 50 000
and
we need to find some money to move back
in there representative emerick do you
have a question
i'm sure would you like to hear from the
director i believe she's probably online
liz gray no we understand the problem
all right
i think everybody understands the
problem
unless she knows what class line and
what a you to transfer the money out of
that's what we have to figure out
do you have any empty positions
funded but vacant except for that one
that you're going to promote to
we have uh two positions right now that
we are in final interviews these are
replacement
positions so two individuals that left
the division of economic development
one retired and one moved to another job
and then we have the outdoor recreation
position
which we've discussed in the past which
is federally funded
that position is in final interviews uh
this week actually
so your position is you're fully staffed
basically
yes
looking at the division of tribalism
travel and tourism
on page starts on page bottom of the
page
591 flips over and goes into 592 and
finishes
on 593.
talk to us about class line 75 on page
592 which is grant
subsidies and relief that's the joint
promotional program
uh which is a match program that we
administer
um and uh with our uh
dmos and chambers of commerce to do uh
regional
tourism marketing so uh we've operated
that in a million it was obviously a
little low in 2020 because we closed the
program for a period of time
and and we've funded it at a reduced
number
of 8.75 per year so that's a mat 5050
match program
in class 69 your promotional marketing
expense is that where we see some of the
rooms and meals money you spend
yes ma'am that's um you see class 69
under accounting unit 2013
as well as class 69 under accounting
unit 2019.
those are that source of those resources
just so you know that's probably going
to be the easy hit to
fund the small business group but when
you get to the senate
you heard my words earlier i don't need
to repeat them
[Music]
okay
i don't see any questions let's move on
to page
593 uh ma'am could i just make one quick
point on that
uh comment uh again going back to the
process that we went through in terms of
prioritization
again the one of the issues with the
marketing budget
and the focus of that right now is that
of all the industries that have been
hardest hit during this pandemic it's
been the hospitality industry
the tourism industry that's been
effectively shut down for
several months now the intention
and our goal and our priority again
within the resources that we have
has been to assist um in promoting the
state
and getting tourists to come back and
reinvest in those in those jobs and in
those that
that very very important industry to the
state so that again just to give you an
insight as to the prioritization that we
had to make separate from yours
yeah uh but that was some that was the
process that we discussed
i understand that and i know you were
doing this in the summer months which
was the absolute worst i mean how many
months were the beaches even closed up
here so
yes but i also know as we move money
here and there right now
it has no negative impact on the money
you have now to work
and we will have worked it out before
this fiscal year starts
together with the senate and i'm one of
these
i guess rose-colored glasses people were
getting vaccinated we're seeing an
improvement and cdc came out with
release guidelines yesterday
so i'm thinking that more people are
going to eat out i know
russ and i ate out on sunday and the
restaurant was absolutely packed and
people are starting to
feel a little relief so some of our
revenues are going to go up
yeah i had i couldn't agree more so
we're just
we need to make it clear we do want the
small business development center to
continue
we want tourism to continue we want you
to be full funded we're going to do the
best we can
thank you page 593
uh we're into a lot of zeros
this is the area that they have already
told us
they have deleted and they're repealing
in
hb2 so therefore you see the zeros
however they exist because it was
authorized spending for the last year
i have a quick question sure
representation uh thanks madam chair and
thanks commissioner again for being here
so in new england cable news they have
this business show i'm sure you've seen
it from time to time and they actually
had a special on the film industry in
massachusetts how important it was they
have a whole agency they
said it brings in you know millions
millions and millions of dollars
a year so is it wise to eliminate this
all together
in our i know it's one of those things
as the chair mentioned it was a tough
budget year but
it seems like at least in massachusetts
this is a huge huge
industry yeah well i think the the
difference really is in massachusetts
the state makes major major investments
in that industry uh through tax credits
and other programs
that the industry demands they won't
even talk to you
uh unless you're willing to put a lot of
money on the table as a state
and so that's been a fact that we just
don't have
uh those resources to sort of play on
that field and honestly
the film and digital office was working
primarily with
um entities that are looking to film ads
so you see the forward
commercial during the red sox game and
it shows them driving along a beach i
think that's in hampton
so that's that's the level at which our
ability to compete
in the film industry has been at for
some time now so
i do think that you know this would make
sense
if the industry didn't make those types
of demands
so it ends up being
an office that um and a level of work
that we can easily integrate
into our existing travel and tourism
team
okay the next we're in now into the osi
division of planning which
i think we have discussed i didn't see
any hands when we were going over it
second thoughts on hands the
commissioner gave us a spreadsheet on
that specifically
we know we'll have further discussions
when we talk about the department of
agents
of energy with the governor's budget
director
i think you covered that force
commissioner yes ma'am
um we're getting to the end of your
budget
and i'm on page 5 96
we can see that under adjusted
authorized where you were
close to 28 million you're now down in
the 26 million
line so that reflects those percentage
cuts that you talked to us about earlier
and we appreciate that you had hard cuts
of your own to make and you're trying to
keep
all of our small businesses and large
businesses working
any last questions from
[Music]
the group representative hatch i think i
see your hand up
yeah it's been up for a bit but that's
okay thank you madam chair
i just want to know for the commissioner
and kind of a thank you um
we were just talking about the torism
industry and
the challenges it has i just want to
note that
um because of certain things and in part
because of the efforts
of of the commissioner's activity
um right now in gorham unlike the rest
of the world
every motel is full every weekend and
half the week
and we have a very vibrant tourism
industry here right now
um and i would just like to note that
thank the commissioner for some of his
efforts and uh hopes
it continues and and that's all thank
you
thank you representative i agree with
you he appreciates that represent patch
guys on page 25 and hb2
we have section 54
which repeals
the bureau of film and digital media
would you be comfortable at this time in
approving that i know we have some
questions coming from the commissioner
on other items
but not on this item i believe he has
covered that
representative emerick moves to approve
section 54 just a moment representative
walls
is there a second to that representative
griffin is there
a discussion on the motion
representative walls
thank you madam chair um my recollection
is and maybe this doesn't exist anymore
that there was a division of film in the
cultural office as well
um and i don't know quite where the role
was in your offices about that didn't
you
i i believe i'm going to ask the
commissioner when
we had dread and cultural affairs
merge and split i believe that piece
went to commissioner caswell is that
correct
yes ma'am uh but representative waltz i
think you're remembering that
i believe that happened after we
actually did the split so we did that
subsequently so ba did exist so you're
right it was a dncr
it moved to bea after the split but
shortly thereafter thank you
answer your question yeah i was trying
to figure out if another office existed
somewhere else in the state and the
answer obviously is no this is the only
film division left in the state
yes and we've not been able to fund it
we struggled to fund other things yeah
yep all right on the motion to approve
section 54 in house bill 2
representative emerick moved approval
representative griffin seconded
if you're in favor of the motion when
your name is called
please say yes if you're opposed please
say no
mr clerk call the roll when you are
ready okay
madam chairman yes vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
yes representative leishman
representative hatch
yes representative walsh
represent walls
i'm sorry i voted no okay
okay the the motion is six to one is
six to one thank you representable walls
for unmuting
commissioner we will get some answers
from you
you know where we're going we'll work
with you when you get to the senate
very good thank you for coming thank you
everyone
appreciate it
we have five minutes before the next
hearing i'd like to do
another section in hb2
i want to turn to section 10
which is on
page six
section 10 says unless restricted by law
or administrative rule upon request of
an intended recipient
an agency may provide documents by
electronic mail
mailing in lieu of mail i was able to
consult
with a couple of other agency heads over
the weekend
they have no objection to this and they
are in favor of moving this
one section forward
representative leishman moves to approve
section 10 representative emerick
seconds is there any discussion of the
motion
see none when the clerk is ready he can
call the roll
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
emmerich
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes
reverend leishman represent hatch no
represent walsh uh
yes okay all right the motion being six
to one we have approved section 10.
we have an oplc section that is quite
large and if you
are looking in your
hb2 it starts on on page 75
and it's the allied health professionals
and it goes
169 section 169
through section 190.
as you know i had referred this to
chairman carol mcguire of house edna
because this is an area that would have
come out of that
and one of the questions was what
happened to the bill
that did some of this last biennium with
chairman jeff
goley chairing house e dna
some of this passed in a bill got to the
senate
never became state law chairman mcguire
read this talked to her committee and
has no problem
with approving these sections if these
were approved we could also approve the
budget of oplc
what are the thoughts of the division
want to make a motion representative
leishman moves approval of sections
through 169-199 is there a second
represent
emmerich seconds is there any discussion
of the motion
when the clerk is ready he may call the
roll on the motion
if you are in favor of approving these
sections 169 through 190 when your name
is called please say yes
otherwise please say no mr clerk
thank you madam chairman madam chairman
yes
vice chairman emmerich yes
i'm sorry the clerk votes yes
representative griffin
yes referenceman yes representative
hatch
yes represent waltz yes
okay seven to nothing manager that
motion passes unanimously
that is the last open amendment open
issue for the oplc
budget i
emerick moves the approval of the oplc
budget into
in house bill one is there a second
representative griffin seconds
is there discussion on the motion
see no discussion if you're in favor of
the approval of the oplc budget
when your name is called please say yes
if you're opposed please say no mr clerk
when you are ready
okay thank you madam chairman yes uh
vice chairman emerick
representative griffin yes leishman
representative hatch yes represent walls
yes okay the motion is seven and no
seven to zero matter one
okay uh one last piece of business it
won't be
a vote at this time yesterday
late in the afternoon mr maryfield
provided some language that was related
to
the section about using mail
and the concern about due process for
people what happens if you didn't get it
i did email that language on to
representative
walls who had raised the question and to
representative hatch
who also meets at home and i ask
lba to turn that into an amendment
we do not have that yet but i believe mr
maryfield
heard distinctly what represented walls
was concerned about
and found an answer for us and i'd like
to
say we really appreciate his help in
helping us make this happen
so that will be coming forward at a
later date
the time being 11 o'clock
we have doj and let me check in
attendees and see
if you are i see jane young
jane i'm moving you to a panelist i
don't know who else needs to be moved
with you if you could help us
by identifying those people we greatly
appreciated welcome to division one
we're going to be on page 196
you should also read it yeah i just got
miami
yep can you hear us
well you're pretty muffled do you have
any video
[Music]
can you hear me bear barely
can you hear me put your volume on
i don't wanna we're gonna echo it's okay
can you hear me now if you're in a room
kathy with multiple people
other computers need to be turned off
and silenced
and cell phones need to be put on
silence you're right we do get in
an echo otherwise so i think that will
help it
so um jane young has joined us and
we can hear you i'm going to turn my
sound down okay because you are echoing
so somebody in the room must have
something on
one page 191
and i think
janet brought things into us
[Music]
no 272 peter
justice all right wrong page for people
272. welcome and thank you for joining
us
we have your handouts that you presented
budget yours we're going to let you
start we will ask questions but we'll do
the best we can to get through
everything
good morning representative ober it's
jane young can you hear me
yes ma'am how are you we're great
so i would ask for your patience i am
sort of guiding the ship here between
attorney general so i am going to do my
best
uh not to goof up all kathy carr's good
work and
in the ground work that general mcdonald
now chief justice mcdonald
uh has laid for us so i will go through
this budget to the best of my ability
that's okay if if you have problems let
us know we'll get him when he comes for
his budget okay i know
so i so he told me he's coming on
thursday so he sort of sent me out as
the sacrificial lamb so i think if you
could at least start with one dig that
would make me feel better
okay you couldn't have stayed one more
week right one
right so uh here i am um i am pleased to
present this budget on behalf of the
office of the attorney general
so you have um our handout in we will go
over it by
one page and as i'm sure you know the
attorney general's office has
a number of units there are two
divisions there is a division of public
protection and there is a division of
legal counsel
and the attorney general has many roles
it is the chief law enforcement officer
it is the chief prosecutor primarily for
crimes involving homicide uh large-scale
drug trafficking events
and uh public integrity matters we also
have the ability to
guide and lead county attorney's offices
and in certain cases
we work with county attorney's offices
and sometimes we assume their cases
if there are diverse issues or if they
need our help
we are also the chief legal officer for
the state of new hampshire
meaning we defend the state in all
lawsuits brought against the state and
we also file lawsuits on behalf of the
state
we are the protector of the public when
it comes to the environment in our most
vulnerable populations
and last but not least the attorney
general is a department head
so in the public protection division
there is a criminal justice bureau i'm
sure that you are all aware of that that
seems to be the
the bureau that has us um in the news
more often than not
we are the prosecutors for homicide
cases so anyone who
murders someone else in the state and
faces up to life in prison we prosecute
those cases
that includes a cold case unit where we
have
attorneys that are prosecuting the cold
cases they are reviewing those cases
those are cases that are not initially
solved and
and as you know those are cases that you
know the families bear the burden for
sometimes decades of what happened
to their loved one we also have a robust
drug prosecution unit we have in the
past
addressed death resulting cases
unfortunately i think that this state is
going to see an
increase in methamphetamine cases so we
are
we are marshaling some of our resources
to that we work
very close with not only our state
partners but with our federal partners
at the dea
in fact we have one attorney in this
office who's embedded in dea
to work with some of those prosecutions
part of the
of the drug unit is we have a drug task
force that
that covers areas primarily in this
central area in into the north to deal
with the rural areas where
some of the other agencies just can't
get there because of time and
in geography and manpower
we also have a public integrity unit you
will see that a number of our budget
requests
are to make that unit more robust
as a result of the leaked commission
there was a recommendation that there be
a free-standing public integrity
unit so we are in the process of
building that out
we have already identified a leader for
that unit and we have
recruited uh one attorney from
massachusetts
into that unit and we are looking to add
to that unit in investigating
paralegal we also have a medicaid
fraud control unit in this state
i will tell you that that unit has been
staffed recently um
we took the last director out of there
to be the chief of staff
but that unit is making not only marx
and here in new hampshire
but nationally we are not only
prosecuting those cases
in getting convictions but in certain
situations where warranted people are
serving
jail time in addition to providing uh
restitution to
uh the medicaid fraud program
we also have a victim witness
unit those are individuals that in
homicide case they will respond they
will
have the awful job of sometimes being
the first
people at the door to tell somebody that
their loved one
um has been murdered they will lead them
through what is also a
tangled process through the criminal
justice system so they understand what's
going on
when there are trials they work with
witnesses to make sure that witnesses
get to court
you know in in the days of covid that
witnesses can appear
via zoom and other electronic mediums so
that is some of the work that
um that unit does also in the public
uh protection division we have an
environmental bureau that is
working to make sure that our
environment and our waters and our air
are
safe and clean for our individuals in
the state
we have a consumer protection bureau
that is out there making sure that
consumers
and that the elderly are protected from
scams
that unit recently has also there's an
antitrust component to that unit
has also been working feverishly with
the number of
hospital mergers we're seeing you know
that there was one recently
in the seacoast area with partners
dartmouth and catholic medical center
are working on a merger
and there is currently a merger with the
failing lakes region hospital in the
concord hospital
so one of the positions that we're
looking for is to
assist that unit in their very busy
practice
and we also have the office of the chief
medical examiner
there is a chief medical examiner and
there is a deputy
and hopefully soon there will be a third
member to that unit to
assist with the number of autopsies that
is the one
unit in this state that is charged with
conducting all autopsies
and there's also an administrative
prosecution unit i think that you have
heard from oplc
that they are sort of restructuring and
so that unit will be
folded into oplc and the attorneys that
are in that unit
as well as the staff will be performing
some other functions
in this office to assist oplc so that is
just a brief
overview of one unit the the division of
public protection
and then we have the division of legal
counsel and as i indicated we
defend all of the lawsuits brought
against
the state um that also encompasses the
civil rights unit
that looks at individuals the civil
rights when they are violated whether we
can bring
any type of action to prohibit somebody
from
conducting that behavior again we're
also in the community doing
trainings with police departments what
to look for
to see if crimes are motivated by a bias
and if so
could there be an enhancement there is
also an election
law unit i don't have to tell any of you
that the extensive work of the election
law unit when there is an election we
try to staff almost 100 percent of the
polling places with attorneys
investigators and other volunteers to
make sure that the elections go smoothly
and everyone has the ability
to vote unencumbered there's also the
transportation and construction bureau
they provide not only advice to
the department of transportation but
also another large client in the state
state police they help them with
everything from
contracts to personnel issues uh to
training
we also have the charitable trust unit
which is part of the division of legal
counsel they register every charity in
the
in the state there is the office of
solicitor general that was a newly
formed
position that office makes sure that
we respond to all briefs every criminal
brief
in the state is filed by this office
there are civil briefs
and we look to speak with one voice
across the state
we look for issues at the county level
at the town level
that may impact the state and we try to
develop the law to make sure that we are
on the
on the cutting edge of rights um
as well as protections for our citizens
and
then we have what what's what i call the
the
the back office we have a business you
uh we have a business office we have a
grants
management unit and we have a victims
compensation unit
so that is just a a general overview
of the office and what we um
spend our money on that we get from the
taxpayers
so if you want to flip through the next
couple of pages
we just gave you some some highlights of
what we had done
as of november 20th such as the amount
of money recovered the number of hotline
calls taken
um the grants managed almost
45 million dollars in grants
and then we also because this last year
has been
so different and so challenging and so
heartbreaking for many of us
what we've done for the coveted um
emergency response efforts i will tell
you throughout
cobid that your administrative staff has
remained
in this office but for you know periods
of time if somebody was ill or
quarantined
in a bulk of the staff have come to the
office
every day through this pandemic we have
responded to motions
we have appeared in court we have
represented our clients
and we have guided our clients through
the challenges that each of them
faced the governor's
overview we are 32 general funded
68 of our funding comes from other
sources
and then uh the next two pages are just
sort of our pie charts excuse me one pie
chart of how we spend
our money so now i'd like to talk about
the
the positions that we are looking for
so in response to your question number
three representative ober the unfunded
positions
they are two attorney positions one of
those attorney positions is a cold case
attorney
we need to unfund that to support other
work in the office and what will happen
is some of those cases will not get
resolved as quickly we have one
dedicated cold case attorney we have
another attorney who is pretty much
assisting full-time but i will tell you
um that the work for the colt cases is
intense
because by that very reason they're cold
witnesses
um spread across the state spread across
the country and
in overtime memories fade when a trial
is
is scheduled there's a lot of work you
have to find
documents that are perhaps older
things need to be tested again and you
need to find witnesses and spend an
extraordinary amount of time prepping
them
so that is one of the unfunded positions
so all of these positions are currently
in
your budget as unfunded correct
these are the positions that we've
identified
representative there's also an
administrative
prosecution unit attorney and as i
indicated
that unit is um being restructured
there's also a legal secretary in the
civil bureau
what will happen is that work will be
distributed amongst others
in the bureau we also unfunded a second
elections
investigator currently we have an
attorney
and an investigator in a paralegal in
the elections unit
what will happen without this second
investigator is
some investigations may take longer to
get to
depending on how the cases are triaged
other investigators in the office may
have to pick up
the work and then the last unfunded
position we have
is a records control clerk and that was
an individual who primarily uh did
copying of our
briefs our pleadings any of our
publications
that work will have to um be shifted to
graphic services we will have to
outsource that work
and the other responsibilities of
working and assisting the business
office will have to be absorbed by
others so then if you um go to page
nine of our handout the new positions
that we are
requesting this is in direct response to
your question number one
um representative ober the positions
that we are looking for are
three attorney positions one of those
will be for the public integrity unit
that i described that we are standing up
that was a direct recommendation of the
leact commission
another is um to address the hospital
mergers
with the volume coming in on those in
the intense work
and another one would be to assist the
division of
legal counsel lee act
also recommended a criminal justice
investigator
tasked with public integrity matters
public integrity matters being law
enforcement officers who commit
crimes in the course of their duties
that is what the investigator will look
at
we get a number of complaints
and calls on those this would be
somebody that would be tasked
to that so those would become a priority
and also a paralegal
to assist um in that in that unit
and the last position that we are
seeking is a director of diversity and
community outreach
this is another position that was
recommended by the leact commission
this person will be a liaison a trainer
an educator um someone who will go out
and work with law enforcement
and work with the communities in which
they serve
all communities to try and better those
relationships
and i think that that um
is my sort of general description of
who we are what we do and what our
current needs are
representative leishman has a question
thank you
uh thanks madam chair and uh
thanks for such a complete uh
breakdown of the chairs questions i
think it's probably the most extensive
one we've seen so far you could
teach it to some of our other
commissioners
to come forward so the public integrity
commission's report i have not seen it
i've heard something about it is it just
strictly law enforcement officers or
could it
be also other public officials
so i think that that so the the public
integrity unit primarily
will look at state so any of your state
if you have commissioners any of your
state employees
it at least the way that it's currently
set up
it is not going to be equipped to look
at
your local selectmen or certain other
individuals
that doesn't mean that there can't be a
case that depending on sort of what the
facts are we may not look at it
but currently the goal would be law
enforcement as well as
state officials uh further
further question uh i
see within the budget and in house bill
2 there's an appropriation for the
internet
crimes against children's fund
is that something you'll have a direct
oversight on if approved or
do you have i didn't see anything in the
budget that had a specific
line for uh i
think that's a pass-through grant to the
portsmouth police department
am i correct attorney young you are
correct so that is a grant i will tell
you
that this office works closely with the
internet
crimes against children task force which
is out of
portsmouth it was mike leclair the last
time but i think that i had heard that
he had moved on but
it comes through a grant we have an
investigator here who works closely with
them
those cases primarily are prosecuted at
the county level
and sometimes even at the u s attorney
level
okay thanks thanks madam chair
okay see no additional questions at this
time
but you know jane that's going to change
it any minute i know
can i add one other thing representative
um so
two of the other areas that we had to um
defund and i think that you're aware of
this
one of um one of them was the
child advocacy centers and i know in the
governor's
letter dated march 3rd
he indicated that there was additional
money to include that in the budget
but there was also unfortunately that
letter
said i'd like these funded but didn't
provide the money
okay so yes that's the letters but at
least yeah that's the letter
he acknowledged the internet um he
acknowledged the
child advocacy centers i know that there
has been a reach out
um an additional fifty thousand dollars
per
year was cut from media power
youth in i had personally worked with
media power youth and what they do is
they go out to schools to teach children
right kids are always on their phones
always on the internet snapchat
instagram how to be responsible citizens
when you are in this
social media realm that was another area
that had to be
cut and so i i just say we'd be happy to
fund that for you what line item do you
want us to cut to provide that funding
within your budget
well that's the problem right make hard
choices so i just i wanted to put a
pitch in for them but we think long and
hard before we cut anything
um they called me and i said look you
know there's less money
the house thinks there's less money than
the governor thinks the house is a
little more
cautious with so many people including
fidelity in our own
market saying they're expecting an
economic downturn and
that we're not going to go forward we're
struggling with money over here so
anything you want handed added we can
add for you but we are going to look for
you
to give us an associated cut within your
line
your budget line that you can deal with
we don't have any money and i read the
governor's letter yes he'd like that but
he didn't send
us any money so we we're struggling the
same as you are unfortunately
i know but if we could all kind of keep
an eye out you know they do good work so
i'll look again why don't you we have a
couple of other pages from you
um as i see this the directory of
diversity and community outreach
reach you're expecting to have a total
salary
i mean a total cost of 118 000 in 2022
and even though the salary goes up
you're expecting the cost
to go down um
in 2000 what's the two thousand dollars
equipment that you're proposing there
uh representative that is um basic
startup equipment desk
computer phone well you've got your
computer under technology hardware which
is another 1200.
your desk your chair
and telecommunications has another 1200
which is your phone
so uh my director of administration is
just telling me it's sort of the hard
startup it's the chair
it's the desk it's things of that sort
office space you can kathy you can hop
on too
okay office space is typically another
line item
all right why don't we start and we will
go
through your budget line by line which
is probably the least thing you're going
to like
doing since you couldn't convince
the former ag to stay one more week but
we we understand where you're coming
from we appreciate understanding why she
can't see me
okay um on page
are you muted 272
i don't quite understand how class 10
can go down
it goes from what the adjusted
authorized is
in 2017 in 2021
down and then up i know you said you
unfunded some positions but were they
only unfunded for one year
because no it can't be three positions
but it goes back up
how did that happen are you looking at
class 10
additional the additional pay period is
in 22
but it goes up in 23.
so those are handed to us
those are not um we had
removed a position um
we unfunded it and those are the dollars
that are sent to us from through the new
hampshire first system those
you unfunded a position in 2601 kathy
yes we did but it doesn't seem to
show as unfunded yes i know
i know we um moved a position
over there in
in 2020 and 2021
we had moved to position over there and
then we removed a position
um it's a very low cost position it's
the records control clerk
that we just um that i had
that we had discussed um
and those dollars were given
to us through the system a lot of that
has to do with the long-term people
you've got longevity
you've got
and i can look into exactly why those
dollars
are different um but a lot of that has
to do with the length of time people
have been here
and plans for their you know it depends
on when they come in and they go up in
increment
and then they've got their longevity um
so it doesn't look like we cut anyone
but the position that we did cut
was like a thirty thousand dollar
salary range that record
yeah but you're only down twelve
thousand dollars me get back to you on
that one i'll look
okay a little bit more so
other questions anybody else
not on that page what page do you have a
question on representation
representative leishman is on page 279
and you have a question yeah hi kathy uh
so
on 279 uh revolving funds
class line three i'm just curious um
why those numbers all seem quite skewed
like agency income
this seems to be a lot of difference
between last year and
moving forward so what we had done
um is we had carved out
the administrative prosecution unit into
its own
accounting unit and that accounting unit
is on the next page
okay 33.05 and
they will receive all their 100 of their
funding was oplc
and as we spoke um about
that is being restructured and i'm still
working on numbers
i am going to have to be sending you a
technical correction
once we redistribute
those positions to a new location
but that's why you're seeing a
difference in dollars
is we separated out apu into its own
accounting unit so we could better track
it was a one-to-one relationship with
oplc
and that was before all the
restructuring
okay thanks so much okay except class
three on page 279
you have zero adjusted authorized
dollars in 2021
yes and i don't know and now you're
going to almost
3 million in 22 and 23.
and that i don't know why that showed
up that way that 1947
should be a zero zero three um
and because that's where the money comes
from
in twenty one
it's that money should be split between
zero zero
three and zero zero nine and is there
somebody on
attending with you who could answer that
question
it's just so the the two million
thirteen thousand
most of that should be coming out of
zero zero three
and then the zero zero nine there's a
smaller portion
like about three hundred thousand
dollars or so but the question is why
zero in 2021 and why three million in
number one is there there's an error in
21 of where that money
is supposed to be the funding source of
that unit
should be in zero zero three um
and that's an error in
what page will we find that funding in
so we can see it in 2021
and represent walsh you're right after
this
so if you look on page 279
and you see the 1947 no i see the zero
that's what i'm talking about you said
that's an arrow error
you see the 009 under it
representative that's agency income as
opposed to revolving funds
it's supposed to be revolving funds and
that's
then why did your revolving funds go up
nine hundred thousand dollars
so what happened was um we to keep
target um to keep
at our general fund target we had to
move five positions
that are um more
public protection in nature under
this account and the three new positions
the three new attorney positions were
also added
to that so you've got a total of eight
positions
that were um
additional positions to be funded by
cell
funds that use that used to be
five of those were general funds three
of those are new
except on page 279
permanent classified positions in 2021
were six unclassified positions were 10
for a total of 16.
in 2022 it's 5
and 15 and you're saying 9 positions
were added
well there are three brand new ones and
i don't
know if those show up
because we have five that were moved
over
from another accounting unit
from accounting unit
which doesn't really show because it's
the reason why you're seeing the
difference
is because we carved out three
additional positions to go into page um
280 which is okay that's three of nine
where the other six coming from
criminal bureau and you're not going to
see that either because we added
positions in there for public integrity
so the difference between the ones we
carved out and the new ones that we
asked
for the public integrity unit um
is not gonna it's not gonna show you the
actual cuts that we made
in the criminal bureau the moves we
didn't make cuts we moved
positions but the budget won't show that
not the actual well if you look at 2610
it's gonna look like we only went up
um we went down three positions
when we really went down
five positions but added
two positions
for public integrity three positions i
apologize i'm not sure who's doing your
budget now but whoever's over there
could they please prepare a crosswalk
get that sent
to janet clayman hopefully by late this
afternoon to show where all these
positions moved around with accounting
unit
and line so that we can look at it and
represent walls you've been patiently
waiting with your hand
up please ask your questions
thank you actually it has been a while
and my question dates back to
attorney young and the question simply
was are they laying anybody off because
with all this movement i can't tell if
it's
if they're actually people being laid
off
they just unfunded positions but not
necessarily laid off
that's what i wanted to clarify so it's
just movement it's because this
position is leaving positions coming and
i just didn't know if anybody was
actually being laid off and it's serious
the answer is clearly no that's my
question
okay other questions from the division
on this budget
please tell us what page you're looking
at
on several pages okay give us the one
you want to start with okay i'll start
with
278 and it pertains to other sections as
well
uh with number 17 full-time employees
special payments what are special
those are payments uh representative the
verge those
are funds that are in line 17
for increase in attorney pays
okay thank you you're welcome and you'll
see those
you'll see those throughout um
now chief justice mcdonald one of um
one of his big initiatives was to not
only recruit people but to retain
people there was a significant amount of
turnover
there was a study done and so these
allow for
some modest increases in in pay
okay thank you you're welcome thank you
other questions from the division
attorney young while they're looking we
didn't ask you
do you have any sections in hb2 that
pertain to
your agency yes uh
yes we do chairwoman um
we have
the icac so on page 40
of hb2 we have the icac um that we just
talked about
there's an frm appropriation
on page okay talk to us a little bit
about the frm
appropriation is that general funds
uh it the way that it's the way that it
is drafted
the money would come out of general
funds not otherwise appropriated is the
way that i read it
okay so we have the internet crimes
against children people watching at home
that's icac
and that's section 75 and then
76 we have a million dollars in general
funds
what other sections attorney young uh
then we did a technical correction
chairwoman
uh starting on page 65 uh that
that involves the medical examiner's
office that will take you
over to page
this looks a little more than a
technical correction
so this is where we were we have right i
told you we have the
the chief medical examiner the deputy
and the associate
then you have um associate medical
examiners that are out in the field that
actually
will respond to deaths will make a
determination
uh there was an issue with the irs that
they were
independent contractors we owed attacks
on them
we did not uh we had some concern
initially
we were not able to negotiate as we
thought we would be
able to with the irs
we put this in we decided that we were
going to put on a full court litigation
press with the irs and
we were successful they reversed their
position
we do not need to change the medical
examiners in the field at this time
i will tell you that there perhaps could
be a better
way than the way that we do it now
but we're too late in the game to try to
restructure this
that would be something that i think
that the new attorney general should
look at when
he assumes the post in talking with the
chief medical examiner
so for now we would like to leave it
status quo which means we do not need
those four
full-time positions or the 20 part-time
positions to
assist them so are you telling me you
don't need these sections in hb2
we need them to revert to the way to the
way that they were
certain parts of it but some of this is
the policy change so if i
we're on page 65 and it starts in
section 150
and it looks like this is all existing
law until we get to page 66
line 21.
can you talk about that change
correct so we would revert it we would
revert it
things in bold aren't reverting their
new language
over what's in law so from us when we
look at this
our perspective's slightly different
from yours so you may be reverting but
keep in mind we don't know
this situation as well as you do so
we're just looking at this
as it is so on line 21 sherwin the
yes associate medical examiner that will
stay that is our new
third time position that we are hoping
that the um
we have selected a candidate that we're
hoping the governor and council
will endorse so that will stay so that's
an unfilled position that was budgeted
in the current budget year
last time last last budget chairwoman
and then you have farther down
you've renumbered a section but you've
scratched out
lines 30 through 33.
what's the impact of that establishing
the chief
those are the positions of the adme
positions
right here yep i have yeah i don't think
so
why do we have that
does that have to do with the telephone
consultation
can i have one moment please absolutely
thank you
chairwoman can we get back to you on
that one we are having some sort of
internal dispute if that should stay or
go
so may we respond to you by the end of
the day on that one
we would appreciate that because we want
this to stay or go to be correct
when we get there so that's the purpose
of looking at this and while we're doing
that
page 67 and then mary beth waltz is
going to ask a question you have a
couple more
strikeouts in section 156
and additions and if you could just
include
one section 156 in what you're going to
get back
to us it would be greatly appreciated so
we understand
the full impact of these
certainly thank you representative walsh
you have a question
i do thank you so i i we found
i finally got access to the questions
and answers provided by attorney young
and in question five her answer is
uh is she fully funded and she says no
and my question is if we take the
million dollars that's attributed to frm
and return it to her budget for all the
things that have been cut where she's
not able to do her job
i'm wondering if that's enough money to
restore the positions or restore the
cuts
that would make it possible for her or
for the agency to do the job
as required under our statutes
from money not otherwise appropriated
so representative walls my understanding
of the frm
bill is that the money is not taken from
our line
it's taken from what we submit to the
general fund
over and above what we can hold for the
escrow account out of consumer
protection
so the way that i read it it doesn't
come directly from our budget
is my reading of that but if that money
were
taken and and attributed to your budget
instead of given to the frm uh people
would that then allow you to fund what
you need to fund and to meet your
statutory obligations
well i do not believe i'm i'm checking
with
administrator carr i do not think that a
million dollars will cover all of them
but we certainly could fund
a couple of we could the administrator
position and an investigator in the cold
case attorney
we could fund but again that that's
money that's coming out of the general
fund that frm is not out of our budget i
just want to make sure that
i'm clear as to what my understanding of
it is
you're correct attorney young that's not
in your budget
thank you
um so chairwoman continuing on what we
have in
house bill 2 yes also have if you uh 67
number 57 starting at page 26
that is the director of diversity and
community outreach that we
discussed
why would your director serve a
five-year term when most directors i
believe are a four-year term
it's the way it is here so it
that would mirror uh chairwoman the
attorney positions in this office those
are five-year terms so while the
attorney general and the deputy have
four-year commissions
the attorneys all have five-year
commissions
i think probably some of the logic was
they would depending on the cycle
a new attorney general couldn't come in
and clean house so to speak
thank you
and i think that that and that goes into
section 158 those two sections go
together
and that's what we've identified
chairwoman is our sections
thank you attorney young all right
committee members
you were looking through your
representative leashman
uh thanks madam chair
so attorney general young the
frm two years ago we said did we set
some money aside or at least create an
account
to accept any funds recovered or is
there any money in there
in 2016 representative leishman there
was a bill
to the people came and said that there
were private funds that would be donated
if they could accept
if they had a fund to put the private
funds in the state can't just
willy-nilly accept funds
and that bill passed and the
administrator
of it was to be paid 10 of the funds
donated that is in the
charities budget a section of the doj
to my understanding to this date
zero funds have been donated therefore
nobody's been hired to administer that
funds
and i believe that is why representative
weiler when he talked about his frm bill
that we retained was talking about
providing
federal funding the governor two years
ago
put five million dollars up with surplus
in each of the two years in hb2
that was taken out in division two so
that
no general fund dollars were passed on
so that's kind of the history to date
and then we see this money
so still no money
thanks and attorney young is going to
send me a chocolate bar for getting her
off the hook since she's had takeover
you'll get a case
[Laughter]
madam chair yes rub reserve walls i have
a question of the chair
and that is if we pass section
76 and house bill two
what is the effect of that section
i mean i'm practical what page is that
on representative wall is my book
my hb page 40. page 40. thank you
section 72 about the family medical
leave
no 76 about frm
on page 40. correct um that would tell
the governor
that sometime during the biennium if he
had surplus money
he could draw a million dollars five
hundred thousand
in each of the years and put it into the
fund
to go to the frm investors
so what a lapse create surplus money
so no because it's not appropriate the
language says the governor is
authorized to draw a warrant so he
wouldn't draw a warrant unless he was
going to spend it
i'm just trying to understand where he
finds the money
he gets the money from general fund tax
dollars
at any time this is typical language
that
has been in bills that are not in the
budget
in all the years i've been in the
legislature okay
and representative alicia was shaking
and said yes that's normal language
thank you it's just i'm not as familiar
some of you are with this exact language
and i was just trying to understand so
within his discretion he could find the
million dollars
my understanding from talking to
previous
attorney treasurer dwyer
is that he can draw that money whether
it exists in the general fund
or not just like any item that's
in the budget this year this year's
budget which was passed two years ago
before we had a pandemic
we have more spending in this year's
budget
that the agencies are working on than we
had revenue because of the pandemic
which nobody could foresee
and that's why the governor had to take
steps to stop that spending
so he has a choice with that language to
go ahead
and spend the money whether it exists or
not
but we have not voted on that language
we have a bill
that as you know representative weiler
put forward it's my understanding he is
working with a couple of people and
may come and make a presentation to the
us
on that later but i have not yet
scheduled him
i appreciate the clarification no
problem
chairman it's just i'm not as i say i'm
not quite as familiar with the language
as you all and i
really appreciate your clarity yeah
that's that language is strange i'd ask
the treasurer about it
thank you any
other questions as we approach noon
for anybody on the justice we also have
the
um charitable trust
any questions on that what page is that
297 we have medicaid fraud we have all
the things that they do
that they
charitable trust starts on 296.
so i survive at 295.
charitable trust uses zero general fund
dollars
and attorney young is so happy
i don't see any additional questions at
this time
attorney young we appreciate you coming
we appreciate you getting back to us we
will be looking forward
to what you guys are going to send over
to us so that we can
figure out what we're going to do with
some of these sections one of my
concerns
and i hope you can address it is whether
we're putting some sort of policy in
there with your medical examiner that
hasn't gone to a policy committee
but i think you can clarify that in a
paragraph or two for us when you
send that over so that we all understand
and if we don't understand
we will reach out to you
i'd be happy to answer any questions
that you have
thank you thank you for your patience
no problem we're delighted you're here
we knew that you were
had been kind of thrown into the fray if
you will
so thank you for coming okay i gave it
the college try
thank you you did a great job thank you
bye
all right we are going to be in recess
until one o'clock
mr hoffman mrs lavinas
wait a minute mary beth let me ask my
question are you going to do what you
did last time and disconnect
or are you going to just
put up a recess session
we can do either if you prefer one over
the other
we can reconnect at one o'clock uh
let me ask represent walls represent
walls what's your question
actually it's just for you man i'm sure
you mentioned you'd sent me the language
from the department of labor and i've
been through all my email and it's not
there i would ask
it it came last night so dig through it
i i don't have my computer with me
represent walls
with all my email on it so i sent it out
last night to your ledgey email
uh mr hoffman why don't you just put a
why don't you disconnect us and then
reconnect us
right at five of one madam chair i got
other things just not labor you did send
a number of things but labor was not
among them that's my
point it was for mr mayorfield it didn't
come from labor
i i see nothing for mr mayorfield either
last night and i've been through this so
thank you
but i just think somehow perhaps the
email address was entered incorrect